creating a world that doesn't exist is
unbelievable you're one of our favorite
celebrities shailene woodley it's hard
to believe that you've got your Stardust
Kaitlin Cooper on do see back then you
were so young they nicknamed you Mini
Cooper we never would have known that
you'd grow up to be one of the most
successful actors from the show
actress Willa Holland would eventually
replace you on the series but that never
stopped you from moving on to bigger and
better things like when you start in the
divergent trilogy The OC was one of the
most popular TV shows of the early 2000s
and many of its cast members went on to
become pretty big deals in the industry
[Music]
we're about to reveal what the cast of
The OC is doing today watch until the
very end
to find out which three cast members
went on to start on the very same TV
show Tate Donovan Jimmy Cooper was
portrayed by actor Tate Donovan and it
comes as no surprise that Jimmy is often
referred to as the world's worst TV dad
Jimmy was one of the most hated
characters on the show but Tate is a
beloved actor nonetheless Tate as
continue to act since leaving the cast
of The OC he recently played Doug Westin
in the 2019 film Rocket Man here's
something you might not know about Tate
Donovan he's famous for voicing Disney's
Hercules I wish to stay on earth with
her rachel bilson rachel bilson starred
as summer Roberts on the OC and Rachel
did such a good job that she'll forever
be known for her breakthrough role in
2010 Rachel guest-starred as Cindy on
How I Met Your Mother
and she would go on to play dr. Zoe Hart
on the TV series part of Dixie for a
total of four seasons keep watching to
find out what summer's on-screen husband
is currently up to cam Chacon day cam
chicken day starred as Kevin bull Chuck
you know the guy responsible for
accidentally ending Marissa Cooper's
life after leaving the OC cam went on to
star as James in Twilight he also played
jack in burlesque today he has been cast
as Keith Webb in the upcoming film
without remorse
Olivia Wilde it's easy to forget that a
Lister Olivia Wilde got her big break
when she was cast as Alex Kelly on the
OSI Olivia portrayed Alex the scandalous
beat shop worker who dated both Seth and
Marissa since appearing on The OC Olivia
has gone on to star in movies like the
change-up and Tron Legacy and TV series
like house logan marshall greens in 2005
logan marshall green guest starred as
Trey Atwood for a total of nine episodes
he would go on to become a pretty big
deal in Hollywood today Logan is busy
filming the upcoming TV series shadow
play but most recently he starred as
Creely Turner on the TV series damnation
and let's not forget about his role as
Jackson Bryce aka shocker number one in
the blockbuster film spider-man
homecoming Peter Gallagher where would
Ryan and Seth be without the one and
only sandy Cohen actor Peter Gallagher
is the man responsible for playing one
of the best TV dads of all time just in
case I got great take that Jimmy Cooper
Peter has gone on to star in a handful
of movies and TV series since his time
on The OC he starred as Nick on Grace
and Frankie and is all set to play Mitch
in the upcoming TV series Zoey's
extraordinary playlist Mischa Barton at
one point in time Mischa Barton was the
hottest celebrity in Hollywood but
things went south when her character
Marissa Cooper shockingly left the show
although Misha tried to stay in the
limelight her popularity took a hit in
2018 Misha appeared as Kelly Owen in the
basement
she also gone on to star in a handful of
horror movies like Ouija House and the
toy box Adam Brody Adam Brody starred as
Seth Cohen one of the most popular
characters from The OC as bad as things
are from me right now they're much worse
for you after wrapping up the show Adam
went on to have roles in movies like
Jennifer's Body and mr. and mrs. Smith
most recently in 2019 Adam landed the
role of superhero Freddy in Shazam Adam
has been married to Gossip Girls star
Leighton Meester since 2014 Melinda
Clark Linda Clark portrayed the
calculating Julie Cooper on the OC
and throughout her time on the show she
also played lady Heather on CSI crime
scene investigation actually it's dr.
Kessler now on top of that Melinda
appeared as Kelly Donovan on the hit TV
show at the Vampire Diaries
then McKenzie Ben McKenzie portrayed bad
boy Ryan Atwood
and from 2014 to 2019 then would play
James Gordon on the hit TV series Gotham
then start alongside his former OC cast
members Melinda Clark and marina pikarin
here are the things we post daily videos
about your favorite actors movies and TV
series do you love hearing about
nostalgic shows like The OC and One Tree
Hill you'll love being subscribed to our
Channel turn on those post notifications
to be the first to watch our latest
videos if you're watching on your phone
or tablet be sure to turn on
notifications in your YouTube settings
and that's a wrap on where the cast of
The OC is today before you go tell us
who your favorite character was and why
in the comments below
ours was Seth because of how adorable he
was thanks for watching the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time